- [Voiceover] We've done
many videos on Khan Academy
on evolution and natural
selection explaining them,
but I thought I would do
a video going a little bit
more in depth in evidence for evolution
and natural selection.
And I started with this
quote "Nothing in biology
makes sense except in
the light of evolution."
This is by Theodus
Dobzhansky, who's a famous
biologist, he's passed
away now, and what he's
saying is absolutely
true and this is why it's
so important to appreciate
the evidence for evolution
and natural selection
and to understand them,
because before the theory
of evolution, biology was
just about observation
and classification without
having a cohesive narrative
for how all of this
came about.
And since Darwin had
come up with this theory
in the mid-19th century,
we've had far more tools
to back it up beyond just
the observations we had
up until that point.
We have our tools around
dating and the fossil
record, which gives us much more evidence.
We have our tools of
microbiology and genetics,
which gives us even
stronger evidence, so a lot
of times people say "Oh,
it's a theory, evolution
"is it just a theory?"
Well, it's about as strong as theories get
and without it, as Theodus
Dobzhansky said, biology
as we know it and all of
the progress we've made
in biology frankly wouldn't make any sense
and probably would not have happened.
Now I'm going to broadly
go into three types
of evidence in this video for evolution
and natural selection.
The first is structural.
And these are the types
of things that folks like
Darwin would have observed,
that people have been
observing in biology for a long time
but evolution and natural
selection starts to make
a lot more sense of it,
and here we're talking
about the macro structure,
things that we can
for the most part observe
with our eyes or with
a very simple microscope.
The next level is what
we've learned, really over
the last 100 or so years,
at the micro level,
in microbiology.
Microbiology and especially in genetics.
So this has really firmed
up the theory of evolution.
And then the last dimension we'll look at
is direct observation, direct observation,
and this is really where
it goes beyond a theory.
We are seeing it happen.
A lot of times people
say "Oh, it's a theory,
"you know, the theory
says it happened over tens
"of millions of years but
no one was around to really
"observe, even if we see
a lot of evidence, no one
"knows if it for sure happened."
But if you're directly
observing things, well you
know it's for sure
happening and as we'll see,
evolution does not only
occur over time scales
of millions or tens of millions of years,
it actually can occur
and we see it occurring
all the time on scales well within a human
observational capacity,
within just a matter
of months or years.
So let's go through each of these.
So first let's talk about
structural and this is
a very high-level overview.
I encourage you to do more research on it.
You will find loads and
loads and loads of any
type of this evidence.
So the first thing I want to talk about is
homologous structures,
that you see throughout
the biological world.
Hom-ol-o-gous, homologous structures.
And the word homologous
means things that have
similar structure,
similar position, similar
ancestry but not necessarily
the exact same function.
And here you see examples
of a, well as a human,
we would consider a forearm.
You see the human forearm
and wrist and then you
see the homologous
structures in dogs and birds
and whales.
And even though this part
of those animals have
very different functions,
a human does not walk
on its hands for the most
part; a dog does walk
on its front legs; a bird
isn't walking at all,
it's using them to flap
its wings; and a whale,
this is making up its actual fins,
it's using them to propel or to control
their movement inside of the water.
And even though they have these very, very
different functions and
at first when you look
at a human and a bird and
a whale on the outside,
they might look reasonably
different, when you look
at these bone structures,
they are eerily similar,
especially color-coded the way it is.
So these are, this is
a very strong hint that
maybe humans, dogs,
birds, and whales share
a common ancestor, more
recently in the past
than say other animals or
organisms, I should say,
that don't have, whose
structures aren't as
homologous as these are right over here.
And if you were independently
trying to create
structures for what each
of these different species
are doing, it's not
obvious that you would have
such homologous structures
actually be involved.
Now these are all
species that exist today,
these are all species
that exist on the planet
at the same time, but
we also see structural
evidence by going into the fossil record.
In the last few hundred
years, or early in the last
hundred years is where
we've gotten really good
at it, we've gotten good
at looking at different
layers of rock strata and
being able to date them
and say "Okay, that layer
was laid down x-million
"years ago, that layer
was laid down a little bit
"more recent, this one
was even more recent,"
and then looking at
fossils within that to say
"Okay, 20 million years
ago there were species
"around that looked something like that,
"and then 10 million years
ago there were species
"that looked like that."
And one example is if you
look at a horse-like animal.
So this is right over
here, we're talking about
horses, zebras, donkeys,
mules, things like that,
the modern ones, well this
is their bone structure
but if you look at the
fossil record from 12 to 5
million years ago, you see
fossils that look like this
and they're very close
so you see, it's very
believable that you could
have evolution from this
to that, but then you
go further back and once
again, it draws, it seems
like a very gradual process.
And once again, this
happening over, these are from
12 to 5 million years ago,
these are from 16 to 12
million years ago, these are from over
34 million years ago.
And so you can see how this
is happening at a very,
very gradual pace and
the mechanism, and we go
into some depth in other
videos in Khan Academy,
you have variation in species, you have
the environment selecting for it.
The environment might
change or different things
happen so you have different
forms of selection,
different types of combinations sprout up,
they're more suitable for the environment,
they start to reproduce
better, they become
the dominant species or
they take over certain
parts of a niche or an
ecosystem, and so you have
this change, this heritable
change of traits over time.
And so when you look at
the fossil record, it makes
a lot of sense that, okay,
this is strong evidence
for evolution, that the
animals that we see today
weren't just put on, just
created all of a sudden
and haven't changed
since then, but there's
a constant change and
we can see it directly
through the fossil record.
Now the next point of evidence, I will put
a bit of a caveat because
the gentleman who first
created this, his name was Haeckel, he was
a controversial figure,
he had some spurious
theories, and even this
diagram that he created,
it seems like he fudged a
little bit of the drawings
in order to make a stronger argument,
but even with modern
observations, these drawings
are pretty close to being correct.
And it's very, very compelling.
It shows the embryonic
development of a whole
series of species, from a fish on the left
to a reptile to birds to mammals
and another mammal, to non-human mammals
and, of course, to humans.
And you can see at the early stages,
they look eerily similar.
In fact, you see proto gill slits
in all of these animals, which later
differentiate into things
that are more suitable
for what that animal actually becomes.
And Haeckel, he's the
guy who claimed ontogeny
recapitulates phylogeny,
which is a very fancy
way of saying that your
embryonic development
is telling the story of
the evolutionary path,
which isn't true, but
you'll even hear people
quote that today.
But his drawings and his observations,
this is compelling
evidence for life sharing
a common ancestry, coming
from similar origins
that got more and more
different over time through
the process of natural selection.
So everything I've talked
about so far has been
kind of macro structure,
things we can observe.
The next thing I'm gonna
talk about is, you can
think about as micro
structures or processes,
and this is microbiology.
Microbiology...
Biolo, biology...
Microbiology.
And the more we understand
about microbiology
the more compelling case of evolution
because when we look at
even one, all life forms
that we know, they involve DNA.
How the DNA gets replicated and translated
and transcribed is very similar from one
life form to another.
The idea of DNA going to,
DNA coding for proteins, proteins,
that are made up of
amino acids is something
that we see throughout biology.
Amino acids, which once again hints
at a common ancestry.
And not only are those molecular and many
of the very proteins
are very, very similar,
more similar than if you
look at the macro level
or even at the structural
level between different
species, and not just do
they share these common
microstructures and
processes, but the actual
information stored in
things like DNA also are
very, very strong evidence for evolution.
So this is a picture, I got this from,
I got this from the site,
I should give proper
credit, 23andme.com.
But this and you'll see
other data like this
that's very similar to
this, which is how much
genetic similarity do we
have between different
species, and these numbers
tell us how much genetic
similarity at a high level do we have with
chimpanzees, mice, fruit
flies, yeast, and plants.
And the fact that we have 26% of our genes
in common with yeast
is mind-blowing because
at a macro level it
doesn't seem like there's
a lot in common with
yeast, but when you get
at a microbiological
level, there's a good bit
that's in common with yeast.
And chimpanzees, we do
relate to them, their facial
expressions often feel
eerily human, their behaviors
often feel eerily human,
but their genes, so just
how close to human
beings they actually are.
And this actually shows
that even mice are way
closer, if you look at
the entire tree of life
based on genetic
evidence, things like mice
and even fruit flies are
awfully close to human
beings, especially if
you were to compare it
to bacteria or a plant.
But once again, you
share all of these common
processes and the fact
that we can now measure
how far things are away
allows us to create
a very accurate tree
of life, and especially
thinking about how far in the past we had
evolutionary common ancestors.
Now the last thing that
I promised I would talk
about is direct evidence, direct evidence
of evolution, and I talk
about this in the first
evolution video, but the
direct evidence we see
all the time with things
like bacteria where
you have bacteria, let's
say growing around,
and we have antibiotics
that we use in our body
to kill bacteria, but the reason why many
physicians and scientists
will tell you "Don't
"overuse antibiotics" is
because the more you use
it, it causes a very
strong natural selection
process for bacteria that
are going to be resistant
to that antibiotic.
So if you keep using an
antibiotic and the bacterias
keep changing, there's
more and more variation,
well you're gonna kill
a lot of the bacteria
but if even one of them
is resistant to that
antibiotic that you use,
well then all of its
competition is gonna
get killed and so that
drug-resistant superbug,
it's often called, is going
to be able to go nuts
and that antibiotic isn't
going to be able to do anything.
And if you look at
science today or you look
at medicine today, this
is kind of an arms race.
You have this constant need to create new
antibiotics because more
and more bacteria are
becoming drug-resistant,
they're becoming what's
often called superbugs,
where they are resistant
to the existing antibiotics.
And this is evolution, natural selection,
happening on a human scale.
You could also think about
the flu virus where every
year that vaccine for the
flu virus, you gotta get
a new one every year because
the virus is changing.
Your immune system's ability
to recognize it can't
recognize the next year's
because it's changed so much.